.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
LET'S IMAGINE FOR A MOMENT THAT
A CHRISTIAN UNIVERSITY IN RURAL
TEXAS HAS A LAB DOING RESEARCH
ON VIRUSS AS PART OF THEIR WORK
ON FUTURE VACCINES.
THE WORK INVOLVES MAKING THE
VIRUSS THEY ARE STUDYING MORE
PATHOGENIC.
THEN A NOVEL CORONAVIRUS APPEARS
IN THE SAME TOWN AND KILLS
PEOPLE AND SPREADS AROUND THE
WORLD.
THE SCIENTISTS AT THE UNIVERSITY
INSIST THAT THEIR WORK HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH THIS NEW
CORONAVIRUS.
THEY ALSO REFUSE TO COOPERATE
WITH ANY HEALTH AGENCY OTHER
THAN THOSE CONTROLLED BY THE
STATE OF TEXAS.
THE REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR OF TEXAS
IS BACKING THE UNIVERSITY.
NOW, HOW WOULD THE REGIME PRESS
COVER THAT STORY?
DO YOU THINK THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WOULD DEMAND
ANSWERS?
ISSUING CONDEMNATIONS OF THESE
RISKY PRACTICES AND CITING THE
RUSHING LOSS OF LIFE AND
ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES CAUSED BY
THIS IRRESPONSIBLE UNIVERSITY.
OF COURSE IT WOULD.
OF COURSE THE LEFT WOULD BE
ASSUME THAT THE LAB LEAK WAS
PURPOSEFUL AT THE UNIVERSITY.
LET'S GET BACK TO REAL LIFE.
BIDEN'S TEAM LET CHINA OFF THE
LOOK FOR WHAT IT DID IN WUHAN
FOR THE COVER-UP AND THE HARM IT
INFLICTED ON OUR COUNTRY.
GOING BACK TO FEBRUARY 2020,
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC WAS
DECLARED, I KNEW SOMETHING WAS
UP WHEN I ASKED ANTHONY FAUCI
DIRECTLY ABOUT CHINA'S RESPONSE
TO THE OUTBREAK.
>> THE CHINESE AUTHORITIES HAVE
BEEN VERY EXPLICIT THEY WOULD
NOT TOLERATE ANY MISINFORMATION.
>> Laura: I AM SURPRISED YOU
WOULD SAY THAT ABOUT WHAT WE
KNOW ABOUT CHINA LYING ABOUT
CRITICAL ISSUES.
>> THE CHINESE SCIENTISTS I HAVE
DEALT WITH FOR YEARS AND
DECADES.
I HAVE FAITH THEY ARE NOT
DISTORTING THINGS.
>> Laura: SO REVEALING.
FAST FORWARD TO THIS WEEK AT THE
U.N.
DESPITE ALL OF THE CHALLENGES,
TRADE AND HUMAN RIGHTS AND THE
VIRUS.
BOTH BIDEN AND HARRIS WENT OUT
OF THEIR WAY NOT TO SINGLE OUT
CHINA.
IF WE DON'T HOLD CHINA
ACCOUNTABLE HOW CAN WE PREVENT
FROM HAPPENING AGAIN AND AGAIN?
OUR VICE-PRESIDENT WANTS TO
THROW MONEY AT SOME GLOBAL
HEALTH FLUSH FUND, A BILLION
DOLLARS TOTAL.
>> TO AVOID THE MISTAKES OF THE
PAST AND MEET THIS PRESENT
MOMENT, WE MUST ENSURE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
TO ENSURE THAT ALL COUNTRIES
MEET OUR GLOBAL HEALTH
OBLIGATION.
A COUNCIL THAT WOULD MONITOR
PROGRESS AND IDENTIFY GAPS.
>> Laura: IF CHINA IS LYING, WE
WON'T KNOW WHERE TO LOOK.
THE PRESS IS MORE OBSESSED WITH
COVERING A RIOT WHERE ONE
UNARMED PROTESTOR WAS KILLED
THAN A PANDEMIC THAT KILLED MORE
THAN 675,000 AMERICANS.
THE FACT IS CHINA IS HOWLING AT
US, LAUGHING.
THEY GOT AWAY WITH GLOBAL DEATH
AND DESTRUCTION AND AMERICA'S
RESPONSE IS THE EQUIVALENT OF
THANK YOU, SIR, MAY I HAVE
ANOTHER?
THE ORDER OF HOW THINGS WENT
DOWN WITH BIDEN AND CHINA GOES
SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
TEAM BIDEN THOUGHT EUROPE HELP
US PUT PRESSURE ON CHINA TO
CHANGE ITS WAYS.
WITH TRUMP GONE BRITISH CUT ITS
OWN DEAL WITH CHINA.
BLINKEN WAS EMBARRASSED BY CHINA
IN ALASKA SO JOHN KERRY IS
RUNNING OUR CHINA POLICY.
THAT SHOULD TERRIFY EVERY
AMERICAN.
>> OUR NATIONS BROUGHT TOGETHER
IMPORTANT PROGRESS ON A RANGE OF
GLOBAL ISSUES INCLUDING
A LANDMARK AGREEMENT ON CLIMATE
CHANGE IN PARIS LAST YEAR.
WE WORKED VERY CLOSELY TOGETHER
ON THE JOINT COMPREHENSIVE PLAN
OF ACTION ON IRAN'S NUCLEAR
PROGRAM.
>> THERE IS NO U.S. STRATEGY TO
PUSH BACK AGAINST OR BE IN
CONFLICT WITH CHINA.
>> Laura: REMEMBER WHEN KERRY
VISITED CHINA EARLIER THIS
MONTH.
SENIOR OFFICIALS WOULD NOT EVEN
DIG MY
IFY MY -- DIG
A MEETING IN PERSON.
IT WAS ON ZOOM AFTER HE WENT ALL
THE WAY OVER.
THERE HE RETURNED FROM THAT TRIP
APOLOGIZING MORE THAN BEFORE.
>> THERE ARE OTHER THINGS AS
WELL.
WHAT IS THE PROCESS BY WHICH ONE
TRADES OFF CLIMATE AGAINST HUMAN
RIGHTS?
>> WELL, LIFE IS ALWAYS FULL OF
TOUGH CHOICES.
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
NATIONS.
>> Laura: THE CHOICE OF STANDING
UP FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IS TOUGH FOR
KERRY BECAUSE OF THE LEVERAGE
THEY HAVE OVER HIS FAMILY.
HIS WIFE IS HEAVILY INVESTED IN
CHINA THROUGH HER FAMILY TRUST.
GOVERNMENT ETHICS DISCLOSURES
SHOW HIS WIFE HAS OVER A MILLION
DOLLARS INTEREST IN A NEW YORK
INVESTMENT FIRM RUN BY A CHINESE
CITIZEN AND HAS MAJOR HOLDINGS
IN CHINESE COMPANIES.
HOW DOES THIS ADD UP TO HAVING
A CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T
CARE.
THAT'S PART AND PARCEL OF THE
BIDEN FAMILY TRADITION AND
KERRY'S FAMILY PLAYED
A SUPPORTIVE ROLE ALL ALONG.
IN 2009 KERRY'S STEP SON TEAMED
UP WITH HUNTER BIDEN TO FOUND
A PRIVATE EQUITY FIRM THAT HAD
LUCRATIVE PARTNERSHIPS AND CUT
A MULTI-MILLION DOLLARS DEAL
WITH A CHINESE OIL GIANT.
HIS ATTORNEY SWEARS HE PLAYED NO
ROLE IN THESE VENTURES.
WE KNOW THE BIDEN FAMILY DID.
I AM NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT
HUNTER.
I WANT TO REMIND YOU AND THINK
ABOUT THIS, MAY 17 EMAIL
RECOVERED FROM HUNTER BIDEN'S
LAPTOP BY THE "NEW YORK POST"
LAST WE'RE.
-- YEAR.
ONE OF HUNTER'S PARTNERS
MENTIONED SETTING ASIDE EQUITY
FOR THE CHINA BIG GUY.
IT WAS OBVIOUS WHO WAS THAT.
>> I RECEIVED AN EMAIL WHICH
STAYS 10% HELD BY H FOR THE BIG
GUY.
THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT STANDS
FOR HUNTER AND BIG GUY FOR HIS
FATHER JOE BIDEN.
>> Laura: THE FINANCIAL
ENTANGLE.
S BETWEEN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND THE PCP ARE
FRIGHTENING.
THEY CAST THIS IN A MORE
UNDERSTANDABLE LIGHT.
THE SECRET SERVICE AND THE FBI
JUST PURCHASED SURVEILLANCE
DRONES FROM A CHINESE COMPANY
THAT THE PENTAGON JUST SINGLED
OUT AS A SECURITY RISK.
HOW WAS THAT ALLOWED TO HAPPEN?
IF BIDEN WANTS TO SAVE OUR
GLOBAL POSITION AND PUT CHINA
BACK ON ITS HEELS, AT THIS
POINT, HE HAS A SIMPLE TO DO
LIST.
NUMBER 1, HE SHOULD JUST LEAVE
ALL OF TRUMP'S TRADE POLICIES IN
PLACE.
THEY WORKED.
NUMBER 2.
STOP RELYING ON EUROPE.
FOCUS ON THE CHINA THREAT WITH
OR WITHOUT THEM.
AND NUMBER 3, FIRE JOHN KERRY.
WILL BIDEN DO ANY OF THIS?
PROBABLY NOT.
PRESIDENT XI IS TREATING US LIKE
A PLAYTHING.
IT'S PATHETIC IT'S SO EASY TO
PLAY THE UNITED STATES.
HE KNOWS WITH BIDEN AND KERRY AT
THE HELM, HE HAS THIS IN THE